a big report out from axios
which is the Joe Biden yells at his
staff headline Old Yeller
Biden's private Fury
in public President Biden likes to
whisper to make a point in private he's
prone to yelling apparently his
admonitions include quote g d it how the
F don't you know this don't F and Bs me
get the F out of here according to
current and former Biden AIDS who've
witnessed and been on the receiving end
of such outbursts
go on it goes on to list all the mean
things that Biden does to his staff and
how much he's yelling at them okay
the way that this is being reported is
as though this is a leak from the White
House that's embarrassing to Joe Biden
and conservatives are taking that bait
and they're saying see this man he's
angry he's he's a loose cannon we need
to rein him in we need to get rid of
this guy he's just too vigorous and
and aggressive
I'm sorry to see conservatives taking
this bait this story is an obvious
strategic leak by the pro-biden forces
this is prop was probably leaked by the
Biden campaign
and the reason they leaked it is
at a shallow level it makes him look bad
because he's yelling at his staff but at
a deeper level it makes him look good
because it counters The Narrative that
we all see with our own eyes which is
that Joe Biden is a vegetable
the the bigger knock on Biden is not
that he gets angry and fired up the big
knock on Biden is he doesn't know what
day it is he has absolutely no energies
wandering around like a zombie and he
couldn't possibly muster the the Vigor
to to yell at his staff so they're
countering that with an ostensibly
negative story but really it's not that
negative we kind of like it when
executives
get fired up when they get a little bit
angry when they're tough on their staff
it means they're focused it means their
nose is in the details it means they
want to get something done this is this
is exactly the kind of image that
Biden's campaign wants to paint about
him and so what happens they give you
secret leaks from sources close to Joe
Biden just coincidentally right now
while his campaign is flailing and they
give it to an outlet that is obviously
very open to the left wing axios what
they've done here is basically just the
old Ronald Reagan Mastermind sketch from
Saturday Night Live
all I can say is I didn't know
and well we're trying to find out what
happened because none of us know
I hope I've answered
as best I could given the very little
that I know
goodbye and God bless you thank you Mr
President thank you very much
okay get back in here all right let's
get down to business
I'm only gonna go through this one so
it's essential that you pay attention
one Casey yes sir you'll spearhead our
new operation to fund the contrast
Factor
thank you
and Afghanistan needs more money we've
got 65.2 million tucked away in Zurich
now if we hold it there for another 30
days at 7.28 interest that's roughly
four hundred thousand dollars 397
285 I know don't waste my time so this
is one of the greatest sketches in the
history of SNL highly recommend you go
back and watch the whole thing but this
is just what the Biden people are trying
to play him off as right now the knock
on Reagan was well he wasn't paying
attention to detailing he just wanted to
be an actor and say nice lines and so
the joke
right is that actually secretly he's
he's The Mastermind running the Iran
Contra Scandal that's that's
because they're doing here even this
line that they're attributing to Joe
Biden uh how the F don't you know this
don't effing BS me
the
premise there is that Biden knows
exactly what's going on so he can sniff
out the BS how do you not know this but
I presumably know this or I at least
know what you don't know
and
it's just the sketch and it's not true
I I am less inclined to believe that Joe
Biden yells at his staff today seeing
this league than I was previously
they're trying to counteract much more
damaging and I think much truer
narrative homeboy is a vegetable right
now go to
grillblazer.com Knowles thanks to our
friends at Grill Blazer instant barbecue
Perfection is at the touch of your
fingertips Grill Blazers Grill guns are
designed to do everything from expertly
searing your Meats to lighting charcoal
grills wood stoves outdoor fireplaces
and just about anything you can think of
where you would need high power fire to
solve your problem I may or may not have
sparked up a stogie with a grill Blazer
gun you may have seen that Grill Blazers
offers two types of Grill guns the grill
gun basic is a high power propane torch
designed to Light charcoal and wood
grills and smokers burns up to 3 600
Degrees it's 30 inch flame is pretty
much all you need a big bad torch to do
and then there's the SUV gun shorter
Barrel perfect for professional Culinary
Kitchen uses from gently caramelizing
brulee or other sugars and fruits to
rapidly searing steaks outside on the
grill warning the grill gun will result
in extreme Grill Envy from your
neighbors right now go get the grill gun
from Grill Blazers go to grillblazer.com
use promo code nulls for 15 off your
order grillblazer.com Knowles promo code
Knolls for 15 off your order Joe Biden
fading fast he's got no answer on the
age question which was softball pitch to
him by Fareed Zakaria on CNN
you've often said when people ask you
about your age uh just watch me and I
think a lot of people do watch you and
are impressed and they think you've been
a great president uh you've brought the
economy back uh you've restored
relations with the world but many of
these people do say and these are Ardent
supporters of yours
the next thing he should do is step
aside and let another generation of
Democrats take the Baton why are they
wrong
well let me not right or wrong it's a
look
use the phrase again I think we're at an
inflection point
I think the world is changing and I
think I
there is one thing that comes with age
if you've been honest about it your
whole life and that is some wisdom
I think we're on the cusp of being able
to make significant positive changes in
the world
this is going to be an unpopular take I
hate to say pains me that I have to say
it
I basically agree with Joe Biden here
I agree with him in principle
because he's articulating a principle
that conservatives have always known to
be true going all the way back to Old
Uncle Aristotle which is that
with age comes wisdom
I know there are there are some people
on the right who are a little bit more
libertarian minded who insists we need
young people to run the country we don't
need those old fogies to run the country
we got to be super young that's what's
really important I don't buy that at all
Aristotle writes in his politics that
you want the old the older people
generally to rule and you want the
younger people generally to be the
active productive ones who are learning
the ropes and who are growing in wisdom
and then one day when they get older
they will rule
this is why I thought the attacks on
Dianne Feinstein were so ridiculous
Dianne Feinstein is a very aged Senator
that's true senatrix I guess she's a
lady Senator and she
what is she she's 90 years old or
something right now she's obviously got
some health problems that's true but
people are making fun of her for being
old I thought first of all I'm glad that
she's not quite so effective anymore
because it means that you don't have a
younger more vigorous more radical
Democrat in that seed from California
you've got a relatively more moderate
Democrat but two
do you know what Senate means
the word Senate refers to the Latin word
Senex
which is old
this means age
so you want that that's that's how the
system is built now the problem with Joe
Biden is that he's never possessed all
that much wisdom he's never possessed
that that much Prudence he's probably
wiser today than he was 50 years ago
but his view of the country is Wrong
is more corrupt than other politicians
and so that's the issue
but it doesn't mean that we all of a
sudden need a young guy
if you replace Joe Biden with Donald
Trump today 97 of the problems in the
country would immediately improve
maybe even more than that
maybe you could replace him with a young
guy like Ron DeSantis Rhonda Santa seems
to be a very sharp guy he's got a great
head on his shoulders
but even to that point DeSantis campaign
is not doing very well right now in the
Republican primary
I think the expectations for Rhonda
Santos were much higher and right now
Trump is leading by a lot boy what a
great clip that was make sure that you
subscribe to the Michael Knowles YouTube
channel ring that Bell
we'll see you next time